What is that we should be doing
to address cyber security?
How is the task of securing our system,
it is going to be addressed by us?
What are the things that
are available to us?
So one way you can reduce
vulnerability is by
basically following some design
principles that are good for security.
And when they're more secure,
there are fewer vulnerabilities, and
less likely to be compromised.
The complexity is always the enemy.
The well established studies
that show whether it's bugs or
performance related things,
or whatever it is.
Those increase with the complexity or
size of lines of code for example.
So one way to reduce vulnerabilities is,
what we call this economy of mechanism.
Should be a small set of mechanisms that
your system fundamentally relies on.
So avoid complexity.
Keep it simple keep it small.
Chances are that you are going to
have fewer vulnerabilities then.
Now the design principle
is fail safe defaults.
Fail safe defaults always
say when somebody may or
may not need access to some
sensitive data you deny it.
If they really need it at
that point you can allow it.
So default should be denied and
fail safety fault is that
the thing is protected.
Access is controlled.
Complete mediation says your
system should never allow
someone to bypass that monitor.
The monitor has to mediate before
someone is able to gain access.
To the resource.
The idea is that someone who's
there to enforce that accesses
are those allowed by policy you have
in place then you can bypass it and
that's the complete
mediation requirement.
A lot of people don't believe that
you can get security by obscurity.
So if someone says well we
are secure because no one knows
how we do something.
Well don't count on that.
Perhaps somebody smart can reverse
engineer and learn most of it.
So Open Design is good because
we're not counting on somebody
in not finding out how we do things.
An extremely important design principle
is what's called least privilege.
So in systems at any time, essentially
when you're running an application or
a program, you have the privilege to
be able to access a set of resources.
Least privilege says you should
only have privileges for
resources that you absolutely need,
and nothing more.
It's a damage containment idea.
If something were to go wrong, what you
can harm is the set of resources for
which you hold privileges.
We said people are the weak
link when it comes to security.
And that is because we perhaps
expect people to do something and
that doesn't come naturally to them.
Psychological acceptability says don't
ask people to do that doesn't
put excessive burden on them.
So there are a number of
these design principles.
Actually they come from a classical
paper called design principles for
secure systems.
You'll have a link to that paper.
At least read the design principle
section out of that paper.
And for each of these principles we
should understand how does it enhance or
improve cyber security.